all right so after consistently speaking
out against vaccinations for years and
years and years
silk of diamond and silk remember
diamond is alethea Lynette Hardaway who
recently died we believe of covid
unvaccinated
silk is now suggesting that diamond died
because of the vaccine I actually had to
look at the clip I'm gonna play for you
a bunch of times to figure out even what
was the conspiracy theory that Silk is
putting out there initially I said well
how did Diamond die of the vaccine
because remember they didn't seem to be
vaccinated this was what they said about
the vaccine yes we don't need to look at
the community right but what we don't
need to happen is what happened with
Africa when Bill Gates in them took that
vaccine to Africa to vaccinate they felt
like stuff can start right there in
certain parts of of Africa that's what
we don't need to you're not gonna make
black people not the guinea pig you're
gonna be your experience no uh yo yo
project not black yes today Billy yes
the surgeon the Surgeon General was
talking to as a matter of fact he was
trending today listen I I tell us what
we need to know yeah but I always look
at the underbelly of what's going on
that's the intuition in me yeah so
needless to say their intuition LED them
not to be vaccinated so then we go to
the memorial service here is silk
eulogizing Diamond I had to listen a
bunch of times but I believe what she's
saying here is Diamond was poisoned by
coming into contact with vaccinated
people other people having been
vaccinated
killed Diamond by the way she says this
with Trump there sitting four feet away
who takes credit for the vaccines are
Americans being poisoned uh-huh
in the wild
when they want to depopulate and
sterilize a large group of animals
they usually inject one animal right and
then that one animal in fact the rest of
the animals oof so technically and
according to the science oh
it doesn't matter it's your vast or not
ah
as long as the gain of function allows
one injected person to transfer and
affect another person and that person in
fact another person eventually everyone
will be affected in one way or the other
Now understand
she's not talking it's you would hear
that and say oh she's describing how a
virus spreads all right like one person
gets infected and then the next and the
next the next no no no no
she's talking about the vaccine and
what's amazing is Trump's vaccinated and
he's sitting four feet away if you
believe this does silk really believe
this I have no idea I really couldn't
tell you if silk really believes this
then Trump's presence there is a major
danger to everybody who's in the crowd
because Trump would be shedding vaccine
or whatever now we've talked about this
many times before this concept of
shedding vaccine is the idea that if
you're vaccinated you can spread there's
different versions there's you're
vaccinated you can spread the virus by
shedding it out of the vaccine not
possible because the coveted vaccine
doesn't have active virus in it that's
not possible or you're vaccinated and
you're shedding vaccine now that's not
true all that would happen is maybe
other people would end up vaccinated but
that's not actually what happens the
covet vaccines don't contain live Iris
it's impossible it doesn't happen it
doesn't happen how insane is this at the
we believe that diamond died of coven
we as far as we know they are not
vaccinated and silk starts doing the
conspiracy theory that diamond may have
been poisoned by vaccinated people I
guess shooting particles of the vaccine
all around them like a cloud of sorts
these are very very sick people and
there we don't I don't minimize or
dismiss their grief
by any means but even in their grief
they continue to actively do damage to
the world that chooses to follow science
and empiricism and Common Sense and try
to act in ways where we are sort of
trying to help those around us very very
sad and there are four or five different
tragedies all all together here not just
that we believe Diamond died of covet
unvaccinated but there's a bunch of
other tragedies here as well we'll have
all of these clips that I played for you
on our Instagram you can find us on
Instagram it's quite intuitive in fact
you just search for David packman's show
on Instagram you'll find all of these
clips you can also find them on our
YouTube channel at youtube.com the David
Pacman show